Mass Effect Andromeda has lost another
staff member I'm Dave and welcome to
your pursuing new opportunities GS news
update Bioware's cameron harris who was
working on Mass Effect Andromeda is
leaving the acclaimed RPG studio harris
announced the departure on Twitter
recently which will be effective
mid-april harris is leaving the gaming
industry altogether moving to seattle to
pursue new opportunities i've decided to
exit the video game industry to return
to seattle for new opportunities there
i'll be leaving Bioware in mid-april I
had a great time at Bioware working with
so many talented passionate folks I'm
grateful for everything you told me over
the years I wish all the best for my
friends and colleagues in bio air and
across the games industry you are some
of the finest people I know and to the
fans especially thank you for all your
enthusiasm and support over the past
several years while I did this games
thang less than 3 as an editor at
Bioware Harris collaborated writers and
designers to create narrative content at
Bioware Harris works on Andromeda Dragon
Age Inquisition and star wars the old
republic other Andromeda team members to
have left Bioware in recent weeks and
months include lead writer chris live
who went on to bungie to work on destiny
and senior producer chris win who left
to join the h1z1 developer daybreak
games Andromeda was first scheduled to
launch in holiday 2016 for xbox one ps4
and PC but now it looks like it's coming
out in the first quarter of 2017 so does
losing another member of the team leave
you fearful for Andromeda let us know in
the comments section below or find me on
Twitter at a regular Dave and for all
your mass effect news stay tuned to
gamespot com
you